it's an alarming situation up to 10 000
youngsters are thought to be selling
their bodies for money here in france
the majority of girls aged 15 to 17 but
there are those that are younger too
the general inspectorate noted early
prostitutional attitudes reported in
schools as early as the fifth grade
meaning 12 and 13 year olds
the entry into prostitution at an
increasingly young age is also apparent
from several testimonies
over the past five years the number of
children identified as being involved in
prostitution has exploded by as much as
70 percent the pandemic is being blamed
for making the problem worse
the sexual exploitation of women and of
children in particular has increased
massively with covet and the lockdown
largely because more people found
themselves at home and at the computer
porn sites didn't help they made a lot
of content free at this time which
encouraged young underage people to
prostitute themselves
and what is driving young people into
prostitution
those who get into it it's often a young
person running away finding themselves
homeless they search the internet and
find someone who offers them somewhere
to stay for free at first the work
within the prostitution network can be
behind the scenes but soon enough they
find themselves pushed into prostitution
itself
social networks like tick tock snapchat
and instagram are being used to find
victims so what are these internet
giants doing to root out these abusers
well they have signed a global call to
better protect children online
acknowledging that threats such as
prostitution and human trafficking have
been amplified by technology however
they have also been urged to do more
ticktock and all social media companies
must be accountable for the environments
they create especially when their
insufficient policies and practices
leave so much room for exploitation
abuse and harm
the demand for sex workers is being
fueled by profits pimps can earn up to 1
hundred euros a day and little of that
will end up in the pockets of the
children who are actually doing this
work
some see this though still as being a
way to earn easy money
it happens so quickly that young people
often find themselves in prostitution
before they know it what drives them is
fast money that doesn't mean it's easy
money though the power to make money
quickly gives way to realization that
the cash doesn't necessarily benefit
them and they end up in this work all of
a sudden without being given much of a
chance to process it the problem has
become so widespread that the french
government is now stepping in to try and
fight underage prostitution it set aside
14 million euros to try and increase
awareness to try and identify more young
people caught up in prostitution and
also for more effective prosecution of
those who pimp and abuse youngsters but
for many this intervention however
successful it may be
will be too late and for the children
who have found themselves prostituted
already experts fear that they will be
marked for life
charla dubinsky rt paris
you